foreign
[Music]
children struggling for breath the tiny
patients here among the lucky ones
having survived a Syrian
government-sponsored chemical weapons
attack
in August 2013 hundreds convulsed and
suffocated in huta after government
forces fired Rockets loaded with sarin
and a legal nerve agent known to inflict
horrific suffering and pain we know that
Bashar al-assad's regime has used
chemical weapons against Syrian
civilians for many many years and
unfortunately this has been sort of a
forgotten issue in the west so forgotten
it seems Global News has learned an
alleged former senior scientist with
serious chemical weapons program has
been quietly living in Edmonton
of last year yeah residents here knew
little about the allegations surrounding
their elderly neighbor who they say
lived on this quiet street until just a
few months ago very sweet old man but
according to Declassified government
documents obtained by global news
journalist Stuart Bell Ahmed haitham
al-yafi a chemical engineer is alleged
to have worked at the Syrian scientific
study studies and research center from
1974 to 1994. the 2018 Canadian Security
intelligence report says Mr al-yafi was
involved in the startup phase of the
ssrc's pilot plan the purpose of which
was the production of chemical weapons a
subsequent cbsa National screening
division report says al-yafi held high
positions of importance including
project manager and technical director
and later became Syria's Vice minister
of Industry initial thoughts are you
know first of all why are we not
deporting this person and second of all
why are we not considering Prosecuting
this person in a statement to
immigration officials al-yafi denied
ever making chemical weapons since my
PhD was funded by ssrc I had legal
commitments to serve the center for
seven and a half years I found myself
trapped but Canada's immigration system
and a federal court ultimately disagreed
and in 2021 al-yafi's application for
permanent residency was denied the
Edmonton house is up for sale neighbors
say the family hasn't been seen for
several months but with no evidence
al-yafi has been deported the question
remains where is the former Syrian
scientist living now Heather urich's
West Global News Edmonton